foreign
the SCC qualifier second one which
starts in 30 minutes yeah so it's 14
rounds I I failed to qualify two days
ago but that's partially because it
started at 5am
this one was supposed to start at nine
but they moved it without warning so I'm
not really complaining
so yeah we're gonna we're gonna try our
best I mean it's ridiculously hard to
qualify
because it's not enough just to get top
eight today you also have to win
tomorrow
but um okay I mean obviously I'll just
do my best and okay we try to do a West
and uh you know what happens it happens
Vichy what is doing your best mean
well uh it simply means you know playing
playing my best chat and uh you know
what what happens happens and uh okay
csb7 Shabba
okay let's go
let's go E4
okay let's play my
my Berlin line let's see what he knows I
should pay for
generally this is a pretty pretty good
weapon in Blitz
yeah okay B5 yum
move now
the guy like me should be three
Knight A5 Bishop C2 a few castles I'll
go Knight C3
here's Bishop B7
yep
okay B4 is a good move
had this many times
objectively I think white is worse but
it's
very sharp
foreign
yeah I'm attacking D7 two different ways
so
I might be winning the pawn back
foreign
okay what do I want to do Knight cd7
here we can take switch the other Knight
to E5
go away wait I think I see something
wait wait wait I have a move
takes there there there there
yep I think that's
almost winning if he has to move his
Rook
he obviously sees it
that's why he hesitated
no I think this is like really strong
here
yeah this should be winning
yeah I think he has to go oops sorry I
used to go Knight A5
then maybe 95
yeah Knight A5 I guess
now let's just go with my gut here 95.
maybe I should have just kept the Knight
on D7 got like B3 or something slow
it can be a little too jumpy in these
situations the average pep six is a good
move didn't realize that
go the other night
um
oh
okay fine I'll go the other night
and we'll go the other night
I kind of missed Bishop takes C5 some
play but then I guess Knight takes E5
still in control
yeah fortunately I have 90 okay C6
okay I don't really want that pawn I
think instead I should probably just
drop wait I can go Queen C5 also
now this looks this looks pretty good
unless I'm blundering something
which I did
I almost played Queen C4
oh
okay I guess I have to go like this I'm
still up a pawn
there's Queen D4 I screwed this up
I definitely screwed this up
still should be better though
it would be three to restrict his Knight
and then Bishop B3
foreign
okay whatever I'll just take anyway
okay let's get the Knight out of there
at least
or maybe wait maybe I can go A4 first
now let's go A4 first now go here
two I have Rook C4
now Rook C3 and now he's starting to
lose all his pawns yeah okay now it's
winning
okay I can take here I can take it this
way also
um not sure
okay fine I'll just do this
yeah it's still not over
you need to be careful
um
let's go here
the rookie two
okay let's just go Rook A2 I'll stack
one of the pawns yeah that was
completely winning
now it's easy just get my king in okay
we won the first one
nice okay I was not playing great in the
middle game though
I'm just checking where I went wrong
this was good
it's good
yeah Queen F3 instead of Queen C5 Quincy
if I walked into this little trick
I mean I'm still plus plus 1.5 here so
I don't think I ever relinquished the
advantage
I rookie two
I guess I just go back to E3 okay
whatever
okay bad you're oh
nasty pairing this guy's good
definitely a nasty pairing
okay let's go principled E5 D5
okay he's gonna play Reverse perk
maybe this is all kind of theory
well I can play H6 I can play Bishop G4
yeah let's go Bishop G4 let's try to be
aggressive
and now I never know what to do
let's just make an improving move
C3
sorry still a little bit adjusted but
okay
um Bishop Buffet
there's definitely something going
around in Toronto
let's go here
ah it goes default maybe I should have
got Knight C5
no no I'm I'm totally fine it's just
literally the only thing remaining
yeah I'm already worse like I I'm
getting totally outplayed by this guy
I think totally outplayed
five maybe
I'm even worried about G4 at this point
okay I want to go Knight B6 but it's a
little bit slow
okay Bishop F3 I'm not worried about
actually that I think gives me
that that lets me breathe easier
that definitely oh my God about ba Jesus
but then I have
still all right I think
we'll make it work
s
yeah I think I'm fine now it goes C4 so
that's a bailout move
okay A B
I guess he wants C5 notice if I have
Knight A4
ibcb simply
and if Knight C4 that's just a try I
guess
Knight A4 is also a move I guess
let's try it
Knight A4 CB Knight B2
Queen B2
B
but I shouldn't be worse here I mean
he's got no Bishop
go A4
try to fix the pawns but then I create a
weakness of my own
um it's really hard to make this
determination accurately
I don't really need a win in this game
though so maybe I should play with no
risk
yeah let's play a little bit more
risk-free with Rook D3 I think A4 is
very positionally risky if I lose B5
and he's playing like really really
solid
Queen C2 loses the queen queen B7 Queen
E7 Maybe
it's so it's a hard position to play for
some reason
if I can make him go Rook B1 then I go
Rook C8 and maybe I have a tiny pool
yeah he does go Rook would be one
yeah but now okay here
be solid
and go Queenie oh wait wait SolidWorks
C4 oh now now I have an advantage
now I have an advantage
okay wait what
can't I just take I can also take there
I don't know which one to take Rook take
C4 might win both pawns but Rook takes
before forces the trade
um I'm gonna play like a Soviet school
boy and play Rook before
probably a mistake but okay whatever now
I have no risk
I'm not risking
and I'm getting outplayed
I'm gonna go here
foreign
[Music]
foreign
oh my gosh I lost it
man that's just unlucky
that's just highly highly unlucky
yeah Knight F6 and I get mated somehow
yeah Knight G4 is an insane move
I guess I should go 96.
9 F6 King HJ yeah here I'm probably
winning
yeah amazing Bishop G7 does not work oh
I also Blended the Knight on C5
yeah that was just a mental collapse no
but I'm just completely winning already
totally over the hump
anything Queen D6 any move
well actually not any move but probably
Queen D6
yeah somehow we found this Knight G4
trick with no time
yeah this stuff always happens in these
qualifiers
maybe Queen C6 is better I don't know
that after Queen F3 it's already over
but somehow we found these ridiculous
defensive moves
but okay whatever
yeah
amazing
yeah it's unbelievable that this
position is just losing
geometry
let's try to win the next couple
foreign
position
I don't need a perfect score to qualify
so if I win like five or six in a row
I'll be back in the tournament if I lose
another one though we might as well
withdraw
yeah it's not looking winnable
okay I want to go here and then maybe
here
he sees right through it
I guess he just says Queen H4
oh F5 well I also missed that
okay I'm getting crushed
simply
Knight F3 F4
Bishop D2
Maybe
I don't know that's risky but I'll try
it
oh F4 I have H4 maybe on the Knight G5
I'm sure there's a defense but it's a
tricky idea
ah this is the defense yeah I didn't see
that either
but these guys are
really bring their a game in in
qualifiers
I think I'm borderline lost
Bishop D5
and if he moves his Knight I have Knight
F7
uh Bishop V8 wow
really
let's try this move
okay goes back to C8
and obviously draw is not acceptable
but I I don't even think I have an
alternative I mean I have no moves
I guess Bishop D5
97 I think forces me to make a draw
yeah maybe these are the guys that
should be playing in
when I stream not three thousands
yeah I have no choice Bishop F7 is the
only way I see to stop Bishop E8
but obviously that's just
absurdly risky
I mean maybe I should try it because a
draw basically puts me out of the
tournament
okay let's try it
obviously this is like I would never
make this decision normally but
I have to I have to give it a shot
okay wait bishop8 is maybe not the best
way to punish me though
because now if he takes with the Rook
ever okay six
okay if it should be it was actually
kind of placid
okay but he has C4 wow
yeah I didn't see that either
should be one
defend F2
okay maybe C4 is not that dangerous
he has no Bishop F2 I'm defending the
Rook
okay let's try to take
I guess I'm blundering something but I
go here I thought
I'm hanging by a single oh he's got this
move
yeah he's got that move I didn't see
that
I guess ah there's a piece or wait no I
guess I don't lose a piece
Rook F3 no I have three of this
okay wait Queen B2
okay I guess I'll go
here
still far from over
I mean these guys are just so tricky
now I should be able to win
that easy Jesus
okay but the plan in the game should be
winning
don't take the pawn I'm under the queen
[Music]
wow that was a tough one
barely barely
she's yeah these people are monsters
total monsters
okay so I thought it was all basically
Theory
but I guess this just allows black to
equalize
this whole Knight D5 operation
yeah already here I'm much worse
F6 is correct as is King h8
yeah here obviously Bishop F7 Rook F7 I
think was winning and I saw that move
yeah Bishop ba was a really bad move
that gives me
new lease on life
yeah and queen E5 is a challenging move
to refute
Queen F7 only way to get an advantage
this is already bad
and this just wonders of Peace yeah
did I miss Maiden one I'm totally not
surprised if I did
entirely possible
but if you could point point out where
I'd appreciate it
okay cosac 12.
yeah another must win
yakub kostakovsky never heard of him
okay let's play Cairo to get an
unbalanced position early
in 1964 Knight C6
yeah I don't know this line very well I
think G6 is the move
I mean
I think you're supposed to go like this
I'm gonna trade the Bishops
never know which Bishop I should trade
in such positions
I guess black is worse
yeah he played the most annoying line
this is gonna be very hard to win
I'm worried about Queen H4 and queen H3
then I guess I go H Knight F5 and H5
Maybe
okay drops it back he probably wants
Rook D1 no he goes before
I mean that's a pretty fun
it's definitely a free pun
okay I don't buy any of what he's doing
right now because Knight G5 I have
Knight D4
66.
oh that was his idea okay then I missed
that completely
let's just go back to T5
I forgot about Queen C6 there
so I should be fine
thanks
he goes back to C2 I think I'll go
Knight D4
at least I got him to think finally
Queen C2 I guess Queen B7 is a move to
prepare okay C8
goes B4 hmm
can take and go Knight D4
how am I winning that
and
I think I have to try
I don't have no idea I'm winning this
game but
my Apon is too far back I think okay
okay takes
Bishop B7 maybe I can try Rook B2
I also go Rook B7
over the seventh rank
gonna oh wait Rook B6 is also
interesting
actually Rook B6 makes the most sense to
me
hmm
yeah I missed that move as well
okay but I guess now I can push
oh he goes Bishop C5
wow
okay whatever
yeah
you can't take that's good I'm
threatening Rook C8 if I can get a pair
of Rooks off the board I should have
good winning chances
yeah this is a tricky position for white
to defend
foreign
good move
let's push
here I guess it's gonna be a race
between the a pawn and the fact that he
has
this idea of okay goes rookie three
wait do I not have so close to being
able to just win outright
but I don't quite have the way to do
that let's just go here
trying to make an open-ended move
because he's in severe time pressure if
we're okay seven I have Bishop D4
winning I'm actually threatening to take
and go Rogue B1 and Bishop E5
okay wait
there must be a win here I first of all
I can
wait I think I see the win I think just
takes
and here is over
[Music]
G
GG that was a solid game I didn't panic
in a worse position and out of the
opening
and that the game I lost really stings
though that that was not not good
but this stuff tends to happen a lot in
qualifiers of every and money
tournaments
Queen D5 is a good move
yeah this was good too I think I found
the only
the only way to play to play for the win
no this is actually well played End Game
by me I think
yeah L Miracle thank you
I need about 10 and a half out of 14. so
I've already burned a point
there is a small break after round four
so
okay there aren't that many people
who've got a perfect score
there's there's gonna be like a couple
well I didn't claim I messed up the
opening I was definitely worse
I'm not exactly sure where I went wrong
thank you Decker for the prime
thank you jarbs for the 21 months
yeah it really was
taking on A3 Mission buffet was also
winning I'm pretty sure yeah no but here
he has Rook takes G7 he has like a
little intermezzo
and of course this should be winning but
it's a little bit more work
it's a little bit more work
yeah Ko's tomorrow if I qualify and if I
don't I'm commentating
I don't know why I lose a lot of my time
scrambling ability in these these types
of tournaments I just don't fully
understand
why this always seems to happen but it
is what it is
yeah Bishop G7
I guess 96 yeah I had to find this move
okay I have been known to win a game
with increment from time to time
my GM title did not entirely come from
three plus so events
okay there we go oof Chicago that's
nasty pairing okay
not my favorite opponent
yeah I don't know Knight F6 at all like
I literally don't know this move
she's gonna go Knight C3
foreign
dragged into another one of these random
lines
295
yeah I mean he knows he knows all the
theory here
I think I'm just much worse
losing him I knew I was losing a pawn
but I didn't realize I have no
compensation
let's go here
rookie one B3 Bishop B2 maybe is that
setup will yield something
I actually got him to think
[Music]
yeah I want to go Bishop B2 and queen G4
generate some compensation
along the lines of
pressure on H7 a few castles
hey I got him to think which is good
okay I guess I should develop
let's try C4
making all the moves that I was afraid
of
like every one of them
let's go G3 H4
should I knock the queen out of there
have it just goes d65 and
pretty straightforwardly
winning
I guess I should go B4
Queen H6
Queen F6 oh because I don't have pin H5
anymore I forgot that
and nothing going for me right now
my sister's busted
I never got any compensation
[Music]
okay I need to get him low on time
that's that's really the only chance
I need to get him he gets nervous and
time pressure
five Bishop D5
okay obviously losing but
maybe we can try to fight
Bishop D2 and B4 is
the hope
that's not really good move
it's a really good move
wow wait let's try this
yeah but he just does this
not much Happening Here
oh it is a fortune
ah he's got this move oh my gosh oh
what I'm I mean I'm just out of my mind
right now I'm just totally out of my
mind
yeah okay
it should be seven I thought I'd already
recovered but no this guy broke F7
it's another trick
yeah now it's just over
uh but Rook C7 just Rook E8 so that
wasn't even a chance
oh just Queen B7 obviously was it was a
try
didn't even see that move
now Bishop E7
yeah I'm too tired to be playing right
now unfortunately
and obviously I shouldn't have gone for
this line I think white is already much
worse
foreign
something like this would have been
better
six Bishop B2
because he doesn't have D5 yeah Bishop
D3 was a garbage mouth
passive
and sc4 it's another mistake C3 instead
was better
open the center
C4 makes no sense
now P4 was another chance takes takes
here
here
in Bishop E3 and white is totally fine
I rejected this because of Queen F3 but
I have Queen B1 and Bishop E4
I had too many mistakes
now this is a brutal qualifier I mean
there's a galcon three out of four it's
just
yeah
no words
foreign
basically need to run the table
I still have a chance 12 out of 14
definitely qualifies but
I mean that will require a total 180.
thanks God zero for the tier one
I mean I don't know how saying that's a
tough pairing
qualifies as complaining but okay
we're saying I don't know the opening is
that like not allowed now
I mean okay
all right
25 20. let's try to win this game
all right goes A3
all right
this is already bad for white
whatever let's just go H5 I'm gonna go
h4h3
well that was not the right approach
okay that's a free Queen
I think he actually was doing all right
after castles
[Music]
okay illiano
okay well yanov
yeah definitely not a softer pairing but
I don't know what even to play Let's Go
Again same I should probably play E4
plays a Berlin No he goes
yeah I don't know this line at all I'll
just go D3 into something total sideline
total sideline just D3 Bishop E3
foreign
nothing here
before I'm trying to stop like Rook A5
but I don't know I mean this is
gonna be a hard position to generate
chances in
okay he does okay takes which is
not too scary
drop the bishop back maybe
yeah drop the bishop back get it out of
the vulnerable spot
it's gonna be A3 or A4 I don't know
no clue A3 defense the pawn but I don't
really want to play C4
I also don't want to allow rookie I mean
rookie 3 is not too dangerous so let's
go Knight F1
for now
perhaps Knight G3 was better
okay I want to go a four probably and
then Rook D1
I don't know
both moves are bad
yeah this is
damn so they got the order of captures
correctly
wait let's control the file
can I play for a little edge here is the
question
go A4
okay definitely now I'm probably the one
pushing but
it's way too solid I think for me to
really have anything realistic here oh
the Knight F4 I'll go King H2 and then
G3 chase the Knight away
keep trying keep trying to get them low
on time
I'm obviously threatening H4
perhaps I could have traded and gone
yeah maybe that was better but I like
food no no no so what am I doing
would have been a disaster
I think I should go like this
like you wrote to FM I wrote to FML
Knight B6 Rook D7
no this is this is starting to get
unpleasant for black
still not sure I have anything concrete
but
okay let's go Rook D7
yeah I'm just gonna squeeze him here
okay I don't see any game-winning
tactics so let's just okay
yeah I should probably go Roxy salmon
actually
oh it works C7 I can always go 9p6 when
I want to
such as now
okay I'll just connect my other mic
it's too much work
the free rook by the way
thank you that was a nice game I
squeezed him
all right this is yeah
it was a nice game though it's kind of
overtaken by the mic but I think the I
managed to squeeze him in the end game
okay sergoy
Cam and Voice or better before okay
hopefully the mic is acceptable at least
yeah there's just no winning until I'm
back in Charlotte
I can have literally I can invite
the world leading sound expert into my
room and he can work on it for six hours
and it still won't be good enough
okay goes D5 so petrosion variation
thank you bloody
yeah
I never remember what to do here I think
I'm supposed to go here
I think I'm supposed to go here or maybe
A5 was the mall
you're the world's leading sound expert
it sounds fine that's reassuring
thank you vibing hoodie
I think the move is A5 because now he's
got this A3 line which is annoying the
idea is Knight H4 Knight F4 obviously
that's why we keep the queen on d8 in
such a positions wait no this is good
for black I think
this is good for black
[Music]
yeah I feel like I'm getting picked
apart today and I'm not like
I don't know
I'm just playing chess
okay
[Music]
we want to go F5
I don't know what to do here F6 is
interesting then he moves his Knight
back
could go F5 okay let's just go F5
he takes it I'll take back
to G3 no he's not Korean he's definitely
Russian
I'm pretty sure I know who this is
it's not kriyakin no no it's not
kriyakin but it's
it's a Russian GM
okay is my mic if my mic is quiet then I
can raise the game let's just let me
know
looks like it's fine
sure right
gotta go Knight d70 495
H3 H4
okay let's go E4
going downhill
[Music]
kind of
foreign
[Music]
natural moves but
position is unpleasant
[Music]
okay I can repeat but
I think I'll take this opportunity to
try to improve my position
oh I had a no I didn't have it before
but I should keep it in mind
I did not have a form but I should keep
it in mind
ah he's got this move again
it's a nasty one
the nasty one
I don't know let's just go here
yeah with the H file open it gets really
dangerous
if I can trade his is this but
I do have this move
what if I go there try to greedily keep
my material advantage
unwise but
let's see
foreign
actually probably should suck the queen
now F3 rfg
[Music]
let's go have a g
oh he's got this checks and play which I
completely forgot about
what's happening now
foreign
tough game
cool that was a that was a difficult one
to pull out but we managed
that's a very important one actually
because now I'm sort of back in the
thick of things
well the queen sack was just a practical
decision I could tell he would have a
hard time stopping my Pawn
no but Queen E7 doesn't win on the spot
my friend I did see that move
I did see that move
I don't think Queen E7 wins on the spot
I mean probably I'm wrong but here here
I saw this line and then H3 I thought he
loses
or at the very least I I'm not really
risking
no I I can't can't afford to make oh
this actually probably is a draw here
here
I think black cannot afford oh actually
Knight E2 oh he's got 92.
oh that's the move
I did see Queen E7 but I didn't see
Knight E2
yeah I mean it's all very easy when
you're when you're looking at the bar
yeah I have to go like this but this is
this is lost yeah
yeah no I I I missed that
probably I should go Bishop C3
might be the only move
and that needs to
check here
here I think this is a dry I wonder what
the
computer eval is
yeah it's a draw oh no it's not a joke
oh you can go you can go Queen d8 check
Alex IX thanks for the prank you can go
like this that's the winning move and
then takes the seventh check that's what
was missed
yeah instead
no this is all like basically correct
yeah that we played all the like the top
moves
page six all of them
page five minutes seven
yeah then I somehow zigzagged my way
around
nice that was a good game
that's true okay yeah and I was right
we're playing top or lowest rated guys
six and a half which is Chicago
some extra guy off
all right hello mix team
that's gonna be three which I usually do
yeah I kind of like these positions
yeah Chicago is always super super good
in these types of positions and in these
types of tournaments
good D3
could go Knight C3 it's hard to
okay let's go Knight C3
yeah five is what I was kind of worried
about
[Music]
very loud
not a big fan of what's Happening Here
but it's just a position
all right
sorry
I
mean
knowledge I can do there
okay I want to go through the E5 Square
gotta control that square
yeah actually now now I think my
position is decent
now I think my position is pretty decent
and explain this kind of like in a
crunch
he wants a bishop B8 now he takes him
good deform
yeah white is better
yeah buddy maybe I should have gone D4
straight away who knows
I don't see a compelling reason not to
take this Pawn
I do not see a compelling reason not to
take this Pawn
it's because work F5 I can play a bunch
of different things
there's Knight F7 okay
where it's that makes sense
it's a good move
it's a really good move
Queen H5 is interesting
foreign
Advantage because he's super super
tricky in time pressure
so we need like 40 seconds
yeah this is this is uh pretty promising
it's promising
five seconds for black
three seconds he's gonna move
he just let us talk right now but he's I
mean he's basically lost here but I'm
surprised he didn't even try to make a
move
yeah that's weird we'll take it
no but it's it's winning I mean it's
like plus two
it's like plus two yeah
solid game another solid game
yeah but now we have another must win
and then we'll if we win the next one
we'll have eight out of ten and then
you know we'll start talking about
a decent result
okay I have seven out of nine now
three GMS in a row
easy clap
I think my performance rating is like
back to 3100 in this tournament
yeah definitely in the running for sure
especially if the top results go like my
way Judah is playing solemn
solemn should be winning this wow
dude is gonna have seven out of nine too
he might play him
yeah so I'm crushing
solemn is crushing
thank you remper for the five gifted
Subs appreciate it
thank you very much
that's awesome
lots of and thank you Rory mmcc for the
sub as well
much appreciated
yeah dude is a resilient guy though he's
not gonna go down easily thank you hudon
gz for the prime let's go
19 months
I think white can actually take that
pawn
no this is gonna be hard to defend
though solemn is two seconds
this is Knight F2 and Judas holding on
no I don't think white is gonna win this
I think White's gonna lose
and Judah look at how he's now he has a
basically a fortress oh my God
it's all has to be careful because
oh good night
seat five apparently is the only move
no now it's lost now white is lost
[Music]
yeah now white is lost
should have watched the end game videos
you can eat two maybe wait still not
totally over I've seen these types of
games and in drugs
yeah but I think so I'm gonna squeeze
this one out
now black and start pushing
actually wait is this a fortress
[Music]
could be Fortress
[Music]
Bishop f8 just induce luzman
Knight D3 apparently was the move now
Knight D3 and I think it might be a draw
yeah night before Knight D3 no this is a
draw
amazing
although B2 B2
oh he had to move his King what was 91.
oh my God 91 was total self-destruction
just he literally just had to keep the
Knight on D3 just go here
and it's just a dead draw like black
literally has no moves because the
moment you play King A1 you go Knight C1
anyways we're playing Rasmus so
pretty strong opponent but we can beat
him
camera SMS
okay let's
[Music]
um
maybe we can go B5 now let's go G6 let's
let's go with what I know
let's stick to what I know
yeah I don't really mind a perk
structure
I don't really mind a G3 perk
yeah usually they take with a bishop
here
yeah 92 he knows all the ideas
this is a nasty position
I wanted to go here
hanging by a thread already yeah but I
missed I thought I maybe go here
but I miss queen D6
yeah I forgot about Queen D6
I don't know how bad it is but it
doesn't look good
if Knight D6 I guess I have rookie six
still in the game
[Music]
okay does go Queen D6
get a rookie six obviously
I guess he goes okay D1 no he goes E5
okay I have to play 95 I think
wait no this doesn't look that bad if I
can wind my way out of it
okay wait Rook d8
guess Rook date is the move
you can also go Bishop p7
I'm not sure what to play
it's not sure what to play
it should be 70's got Knight B5 so
I actually think I should go here
and I want to keep the bishop here so
maybe I should go back to E7 actually
the ship E7 also Bishop C7 is
interesting I'll go here
too slow
it's a little faster
yeah Knight B1 probably should go Knight
DB1
foreign
takes takes 97 Knight C4 Knight C5
Knight B6 94.
complicated very hard to evaluate
but it feels
feels right I don't know it just feel
right
[Music]
also rookie 3 if he takes is interesting
maybe even stronger
yeah probably rookie threes the way
probably this is the way
yeah here
[Music]
oh this is a nasty move but I can take
Rook C7
[Music]
okay
not sure if I should push or what
I don't know
I think it's a drum
okay we gotta push
[Music]
okay I have a bunch of moves here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
stick here and try to win this
[Music]
oh my God move
yeah I got him
we got him you got another one
wow
suddenly I am very much back from the
dead
this is a typical trick King F2 Knight
D3
four in a row against GM's
yeah we're playing solemn Okay so
he's obviously fond of the draw but I'm
not
so what should we play
Ed jababa London
foreign
maybe you can play regular London
let's play regular London
or something positioned like he's super
tactical so
okay he goes for this line yeah Min
always places against me
did I've learned some Queen F6 related
nonsense
should have gone Knight C3 of course
I thought that was dangerous but okay
whatever
now I know Min likes to play up three in
these types of positions
okay let's start with this one
a B4
okay now F3 makes a lot more sense but
still he takes and goes G4
dangerous
pretty dangerous
hmm
okay let's go B4
under B5 C5 he's got
to way too slow in my attack here
typical solemn
always find some way to Checkmate the
opponent
Rook F7 okay I can still go F3
okay let's actually prepare it
all right
there's C6 and probably I shouldn't have
shouldn't have delayed
five no but maybe this is fine
I guess he takes it I take it the bishop
Maybe
[Music]
let's pray move it foreign
yeah this looks pretty decent for me if
it goes D5 I'll Place CD and then FV
okay now I'm up on time which is nice
[Music]
it was C5 wait that's got to be wrong
that has to be wrong
I'm just gonna go intuitively and take
F4 that was his idea
whoa this is a Nutty idea
no clue what's Happening Here
I'm just gonna take it
I don't care
I like literally don't care like oh my
God
yeah
I think am I going to
okay I think I messed up or did I have
no idea
might be five maybe okay let's go Knight
B5
crazy position
but it feels like I'm worse I don't know
why it just feels that way
I can go see five
and then try to go Bishop C4 he'll
probably stack his exchange but
position is pretty close to collapsing
there now let's go C5
four
there'd be winning here
27 E5
it's very strong
at H5
Knight D6 Bishop P6 takes takes takes
everything Maybe
wait I can go E6 first also but I don't
need to I can take
[Music]
rookie two queen F7 rookie zero q1 wins
[Music]
yeah okay we got him
that was a good game
this is a good game
yeah I just I didn't lose my mind in the
Tactical complications
and I got him
yeah the London was a great choice
against him I think because he's not not
a big fan of these positions
he also had the Ed and queen F6 and I
think probably
black is better
yeah but this is like men's credit
because he he know he likes this plan
with F3 and it's actually a super
dangerous plane
uh C5 is the top mode damn I found a lot
of good moves this game
and so is E5
and so is Knight D6 wow yeah I just
didn't give him any chances and so is E6
damn girl
[Music]
okay here we go big game
I'll be black but we can win with black
okay we're playing dude up
we can beat him he's been making a lot
of mistakes
I mean this is really all I know
he doesn't blunder
the trick
okay this is I know still basically
equal
here
should be four looks interesting
probably gonna go bishopy too
and I'll go 97.
yeah we're gonna he's gonna have to get
over ambitious for me to win this game
uh Bishop D3 is nice
I thought I might take and go E5
actually that looks
I mean it's very risky but
I'm not winning this unless I take a lot
of risk
I'm not winning this unless I I play
very risky and we need to win this game
okay he takes it that surprises me
Bishop ah Bishop B5 Rook C6 so I have to
take with a knight I guess
kind of underestimated that move to be
honest
okay I think I can get away with C6
a few castles I go queenies no castles I
go F5
or do I yeah I guess I got five
ghostworks C1 or you do one ah there's a
tactic no
Bishop H7
it's not the end of the game though
see
blundered a little tactic
they have to go like this
I forgot about this trick I should page
seven
but his I mean it's still complicated
still complicated
is this the strongest qualifier of all
time or what I mean what are the
experiences
okay trades Queens
is not what I like to see
but I had F5 and now I said don't
guys just a machine
total machine
yeah I'm worried I'm afraid this is this
ain't looking good
it's gonna go kingy two simply
I mean it all was one blunder
one tactical blender is all it took
try to hold this somehow
but he's playing like an engine
struggles so much against Duda likes
even compared to other super GMS
I don't know what it is about him
yeah there goes the qualification unless
unless something miraculous happens
unless something miraculous happens
which is not likely
no it's certainly not okay
despite the Palm loss
the bishop pair is really what kills me
in this position it's not even the extra
Pawn
wait it goes to Rook takes what
anyway I have to try to make this move
work
oh Rook D7 I see
no this guy's on another level
as on another level
now the material is equal but I'm so
paralyzed
right
here
55 simply
no no chances
I need a mouse slip or something
five it just restricts the bishop
okay but now the only thing is he can't
really move his Bishop
that doesn't help me I don't have any
pieces in the game
and now he can with his Bishop
even before should be winning
it's just like playing against the wall
trying should be five maybe
trying to generate chances here
unfortunately I think he has no e4c ah
he's got this move
just I can only move
trying here
wait now I'm turning Rook G2 though
still a game
definitely still a game
oh what is that this move
wow
guy just is just unreal
yeah he gave me zero chances like every
time I try to do something he just shut
it down
Bishop D5 is such an annoying move
stopping Rook G2 otherwise it was
unclear
I don't even know where my like make
mistake was
felt decent for black and then suddenly
it just got really bad
oh it's just plus one position's just
bad
yeah no he did everything right
literally every move
is the top move I'm checking right now
literally every move at five
Bishop G3 Bishop A6 B4
King D3 is fine
yeah this is amazing
and Bishop D5 like only move to win
cleanly
amazing
just amazing yeah he just played I
wonder what his accuracy is in this game
it's probably in the 90s
probably in the 90s
yeah dudo with block is a raft pairing
for sure
yeah 91.5
he played a classical level game in
three plus one
so it is what it is
all right well we gotta win the last two
games now and then even then I might not
qualify but I'll have a chance
no I'm still Yeah by tie breaks I'm
still top eight right now so I just
basically need to go two out of two
now Judah is just so infuriating to play
against
he's beat me every single time we played
whether it's two aim chess tournaments
and now this and I think he's been title
Tuesday before
no nine and a half is not gonna be
enough for sure
there's yet another break just
I don't know three breaks is a little
Overkill but I guess they need to do the
fair play checks
there we go
okay you think you Yankee
that's an interesting pairing nine and a
half out of 12 yeah so we need to stop
him
give mystical monk the prime
and I want to get a fresh position
that's the point
and I'll play them can go G4 H4 it's
always interesting
yeah let's do it I mean let's play some
uncompromising chess
there's Knight fd7 all right fine
could go G5
that seems a little too risky
to develop
yeah I didn't get much
if anything
F1 King G2
the one thing is it's not so easy for
black to find a good spot for his King
because if he castles King side I have
G5
[Music]
I think I have a pretty solid position
here
that's what I thought he'd do
I want to go C5 Knight B5 it goes B5 oh
yeah I saw that move and I somehow
didn't realize it's good and now I see
that it is
and now I see that it is very very good
guys are just so unforgiving
I'm I'm already in trouble
it's literally all it takes it's just
one little sloppy move
no moves here I mean just goes B4 and C5
but my king on G2 you wouldn't have any
of this
okay
have an idea
I like this
okay
let's just get sliding downhill
okay let's go G5 only chance I I need to
open the file
it goes H5 it's another move I missed
some people are brutal
E3
doesn't look like a good move but
it takes
to the brook okay
didn't notice that either
let's go here
foreign
this game like a hundred times out of
100.
like it would already be over
no increment
I think the only move is 95.
he's six way oh and this has to be good
for me now
foreign
[Music]
let's go got him
the Fantastic game
oh
yeah I've had some good moments this
tournament
that was clutch right there
absolutely clutch okay so draw probably
satisfies me in the last round
yeah Baba for the win
two
oh I wouldn't say G5 works that was
definitely worse
and then at some point I was just better
I think a draw satisfies both parties so
hopefully
my opponent will think the same way
yeah this is already good oh wow this is
winning oh Rook C5 was winning but this
is also good
Bishop G7 is the only move
nice this I'm pumped about this and G7
is also accurate
90. I'm just curious what to do here
oh check and look
C7
yeah this is a really nice game
yeah super pumped about that one
super pumped about that one
okay so let's take a look at the
standings
yeah definitely I would say that a draw
should qualify I mean if a draw doesn't
qualify then I I don't care like I've
done what I sorry let me just switch
back
I've done I've done my due diligence
so I'm number five Man 10 out of 13 and
I still am like
qualification uncertain
yeah I'm gonna offer a draw early to get
it out of the way and if my opponent
doesn't take it then we're just gonna
play
there are tie breaks of course yeah
this is the qualifier for the top eight
so it's not like if I win it's an
automatic qualification qualification
I also might play artemiev and then
definitely he should be fine with a draw
yeah I mean if I don't qualify with the
drill that would be insane
in a scene
so we're just waiting for the games to
finish there's a couple oh this guy's
trying to mate with Knight and Bishop
okay come on
there's always one of these
yeah he's doing it
he's doing it
this is easy clap King E3 and
should be three Bishop C2
or this yeah
wait oh okay this is also fine
wait why would you go to D3 though
why would you go to D3
oh there's a 50 move roll
oh he didn't make it you didn't make it
he he succumbs to the 50 movable just
when he has the king in the right spot
just when he has the king in the right
spot okay here we go last game
okay we're offering a draw and then if I
it doesn't take it we're just playing
yeah okay it's our Tammy if so I think
I think he'll be fine with the draw
all right so
yeah so we make a draw
and we wait
okay side straw with black against her
temues I mean
I don't think I would have too many
chances
the point of that was to gain half a
point and try to qualify into the top
eight
I mean I think that should be pretty
patently clear
there is a small chance that I don't
qualify but my tie breaks are really
good before this round
so we're just gonna wait for this round
to finish
okay that was a really good performance
I think overall I won
yeah those despite those early losses I
managed to keep my composure so I lost a
buzzer Odin gigolco
and do that
yeah it does appear that I'm not
compensating tomorrow
but if I lose tomorrow I guess I can
jump into the commentary Booth probably
no you're good you're good
I know I mean normally I think I
wouldn't be too happy with this but
if if I get screwed on the tie breaks
again I'm gonna have like no words
but I get screwed on the tie breaks I'll
have no words
okay so we want
we actually probably want dubov and Duda
to win
so let's let's see so number three
number four five
six seven yeah in order for me not to
make the top eight something insane
would have to happen to the tie breaks
we definitely don't want grishook to win
like we want as many nine and a halfs to
draw as possible
um let's let's see let's see Jeffrey
yeah Jeffrey and Angel we want this to
be a draw
you can watch it like the election yeah
we're watching Nevada
we're watching Nevada all right
here we go no but the thing is the the
the the the tie breaks only update after
all of the games are finished just
remember that
remember that the tie breaks only update
after all of the games are done
I sound like a commentator now
but yeah thanks everybody for the
support throughout the tournament I
really appreciate it it was a very Rocky
start but
I think I totally avoided tilting and
just kept my composure which is
I'm making progress in that regard
okay but now Jeffrey should be winning
yeah okay Angela's just losing his mind
here Jeffrey Jeffrey should win this
okay so denlaz wins
which is not good if they had drawn I
would have guaranteed quote I need to
have the worst tie breaks in order to
not qualify
I think I should be in
yeah that's it I'm I think I'm
guaranteed to be in yep because denlaz
is number eight right now and he's the
last 10 and a half but let's see which
spot we're in
okay I really need to go though I need
to get to get a little snack before
I am
I have lessons and stuff
I'm positive
yeah we're in
our and the draw was a good decision
and I am in fifth place yeah I'm in
fifth
who do I play I think oh I played dubov
yeah that's probably I mean not that I'd
rather play Jeffrey or like solemn or
temev
I think fifth place fourth
one plays eighth second place seventh
yeah we're playing dubov
in that case I will see you guys later
and I'm gonna send the raid over to Eric
uh Eric Rosen thanks again for
supporting me today really appreciate it
uh this was a super fun event and I'll
do my best to qualify tomorrow
see you guys later bye